in einem meiner letzten videos habe ich
über starling gesprochen das
satelliten-internet von spacex und elon
musk im video habe ich recht kritisch
kommentiert das quasi auf einen schlag
12.000 weitere objekte in den orbit der
erde gebracht werden sollen oder sogar
42.000 in den kommentaren unter dem
video haben uns aber viele von euch
darauf hingewiesen dass das weltall groß
ist und der raum um die erde herum noch
lange nicht ausgeschöpft und das stimmt
natürlich
zwischen den einzelnen starling
satelliten sind je nach menge und
ausbreitung immer noch über 600
kilometer platz
außerdem können die satelliten jahr
manövrieren und anderen satelliten
ausweichen wenn alles wie geplant läuft
dann passiert da oben nichts aber es
läuft eben nicht immer alles wie geplant
und es geht nicht nur um satelliten
sondern auch um weltraumschrott der
nicht fein säuberlich seine bahnen
fliegt sondern kreuz und quer überall
hin und her fliegt aber sind mehr
objekte im weltraum wirklich ein problem
ab wann ist der orbit zugemüllt wie viel
ist zu viel und vor allem können wir das
alles wieder sauber machen dieses video
wurde unterstützt von vivid money money
ist ein neues start-up das banking ins
21 jahrhundert bringen will
hier wird alles per app gesteuert ist
einfach gestaltet und minimalistisch zum
beispiel kann man das geld in seinem
haupt account in sogenannten pocket
organisieren das ist super praktisch
wenn man zum beispiel auf etwas hin
sparen will
oder man sich selber zum ausgehen oder
shoppen um ein gewisses budget erlauben
will
und jede pocket hat dabei ihre eigene
iban neben der app kriegt ihr noch eine
kostenlose metall karte mit der ihr vor
ort bezahlen könnt und das teilen von
restaurant rechnungen mit freunden bis
jetzt auch einfacher
seit kurzem kann man per telefonnummer e
mail oder iban einfach und kostenlos
geld an kontakte schicken
auch neu verfolge alle abos und
lastschriften an einem ort die
bevorstehende abogebühren und blockiere
sie einfach
außerdem gibt es cashback prämien wenn
man mit vivid bezahlen das funktioniert
zum beispiel bei supermärkten und cafés
da bekommt man zum beispiel einfach so
10 einer monatlichen gebühr zurück
insgesamt kann man jeden monat bis zu 20
euro cashback erhalten und dieses geld
kann sogar noch vermehrt werden indem er
zum beispiel mit einer aktie wie tesla
verknüpft
wichtig dabei ist dass sie keine
richtigen aktien kauft ihr könnt von
steigenden kursen profitieren werdet
aber niemals geld verlieren wenn die
kurse sinken eröffnet jetzt ein
kostenloses konto bei wird man den link
dazu findet ihr unten in der video
beschreibung so jetzt geht's aber los
mit dem video übrigens wie laden jede
woche ein neues video hoch wenn du
kannst davon verpassen wollt dann
abonniert gerne den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke dann werdet ihr nämlich immer
benachrichtigt wenn es was neues für uns
gibt
[Musik]
eifrig und was befindet sich eigentlich
alles im orbit um die erde
das ist gar nicht so leicht zu
beantworten seit 1957 wurden knapp 8500
objekte in den weltraum geschickt wie zb
75 satelliten für das gps netzwerk oder
die internationale raumstation
viele dieser satelliten und
raumstationen sind super langlebig
gebaut aber nichts hält ewig irgendwann
werden satelliten und raumstationen
abgeschaltet und das kostengründen
bleiben sie meistens genau da wo sie
sind im weltraum
das bezeichnet man dann als
weltraumschrott also nicht mehr
funktionierende menschengemachte
gegenstände im all das sind nicht nur
komplett vollständig zurück gelassene
satelliten sondern auch einzelteile oder
zum beispiel der handschuh des
astronauten ed white nach seinem
historischen weltraumspaziergang 1985
schätzungsweise befinden sich aktuell
21.000 gegenstände mit einem durchmesser
von über 10 cm im orbit um die erde
gehen wir allerdings unter diese grenze
dann gibt es noch deutlich mehr
vermutlich irgendwas zwischen 500.000
und 70 millionen objekten mit einem
durchmesser von unter zehn zentimeter
wie das aussieht das kann man sich auf
der website stuff in space angucken
die gegenstände hier sind natürlich viel
größer dargestellt als sie in wahrheit
sind
sonst könnte man sie gar nicht sehen das
allererste stück weltraummüll ist
übrigens von 1964 damals wurde der
vanguard one forschungssatellit
abgeschaltet das ist ja schon irgendwie
ein komischer gedanke seit 56 jahren
umkreist ein verlassenes satellit einsam
die erde genau wie intakte satelliten
schweren vanguard wann aber auch
schrauben plastikteile und alle anderen
möglichen gegenstände jetzt gerade um
die erde und aufgrund ihres ortes sind
manche teile schneller langsamer weiter
weg oder nah dran als andere und das
bedeutet dass sie auch irgendwann
zusammenstoßen können
ich glaube nicht dass da irgendwas
passiert also ein paar tausend star
links athleten schlappe hunderttausend
teile weltraumschrott die gegenstände
sind noch alle super kleine vergleich
dazu wie groß das universum ist okay
gute frage wie hoch ist das risiko einer
kollision wirklich wenn die menschheit
satelliten ins all schickt dann in
vielen fällen in den low earth orbit
oder auch i o
das ist alles bis zu 2000 kilometer höhe
von der erdoberfläche aus gemessen und
mittlerweile sollten wir dort schon bei
ungefähr 3000 elio satelliten angekommen
sein
die zahl geht unter anderem durch space
extra lang gerade rapide nach oben alle
paar wochen gibt es eine neue star link
mission die wieder um die 60 satelliten
ins all bringt und so groß ist das
weltall hier nicht wie hoch die chance
einer kollision ist da streiten sich die
experten
heiner klinkrad ehemaliger experte für
weltraumschrott am european space
operations centre sagt zum beispiel dass
man durchschnittlich alle zehn jahre mit
einer kollision von zerstörerischer
wirkung rechnen kann
ein satellit mit 100 quadratmetern
fläche wird zwar rein rechnerisch nur
alle 15 tausend jahre getroffen
aber es gibt nun mal auch tausende
satelliten andere experten sind etwas
vorsichtiger in ihrer einschätzung aber
generell ist man sich einig dass wir uns
definitiv mehr sorgen über kollisionen
im weltall machen sollten
okay aber ich meine ein großteil des
weltraumschrotts ist ja so ein paar
client viel kann selbst wenn es zu einer
koalition kommen wird doch eigentlich
nicht passieren oder
naja außer sie sind um ein vielfaches
schneller als eine pistolenkugel
denn bei so hohen geschwindigkeiten kann
selbst etwas sehr kleines eine große
gefahr darstellen
dieses bild hier von der esa zeigt was
eine kleine kugel von nur 1,7 gramm
anrichten kann wenn sie sich mit 25.000
kilometern pro stunde bewegt gravity war
stellenweise verdammt unlogisch aber der
film zeigte sehr eindrücklich den space
super-gau eine einzige kollision kann in
einer unkontrollierbaren kettenreaktion
enden
das nennt man dann kessler syndromen das
könnte den orbit um die erde in einen
riesigen wahnsinnig schnellen sturm aus
müll verwandeln
das würde einerseits bedeuten dass der
low earth orbit für uns unbrauchbar wird
aber auch dass wir unseren planeten für
eine ungewisse zeit nicht mehr verlassen
könnten
hat hier jemand vermied paradoxon gesagt
dass kessler syndrom ist allerdings
nicht die einzige gefahren durch
weltraumschrott wegen der
anziehungskraft der erde können wir uns
sicher sein dass alles was wir in den
orbit schießen irgendwann zurückkommen
wird
die nasa rechnet mit durchschnittlich
einem teil pro tag das kann eine
schraube sein die in der atmosphäre
verbrennt aber auch die ausrangierte
tiangong-1 playstation die vor zwei
jahren im pazifik runtergekommen ist
oder der handschuh von ed white perfekt
wenn man den abbekommen würde dann wäre
das vielleicht die härteste backpfeife
aller zeiten
wie hart naja wenn der handschuhe
ungefähr 100 gramm wiegt und mit 27.000
kilometern pro stunde auf die erde zu
steuert dann hat er beim wiedereintritt
in die atmosphäre
eine energie von 2,8 millionen schuhe
dem äquivalent von ungefähr zehn
handgranaten
das nenne ich mal eine richtig
ordentliche schelle okay spaß beiseite
bisher wurde noch niemand auf der erde
von weltraumschrott verletzt
etwas handschuh es zum beispiel bereits
einen monat nach dem verlust vollständig
in der atmosphäre verbrannt wir können
uns aber sicher sein je mehr wir nach
oben schießen desto mehr kommt auch
wieder runter das sollte man schon im
hinterkopf behalten
gut also nicht gut aber gut fassen wir
mal zusammen
selbst wenn noch nicht super viele dinge
um die erde fliegen und das weltall
riesig groß ist kann weltraumschrott zur
gefahr werden
denn dass kessler syndrom kann schon
durch einen kleinen zusammenstoß
ausgelöst werden und alles da oben mitte
zwangsläufig wieder zurückkommen wenn
wir glück haben als asche aber wenn wir
pech haben dann verbrennt nicht alles
und brennende stroh
teile fallen vom himmel klingt etwas
apokalyptisch habe ich mir auch gedacht
aber vielleicht ist das ja was für 2020
bingo am besten überlegen wir uns also
eine lösung den weltraum aufzuräumen
aber das ist gar nicht so einfach in
erster linie ist das ein sehr
politisches thema
ein satellit egal ob in takt oder kaputt
hat einen besitzer das heißt auf
diplomatischer ebene kann man nicht
einfach das eigentum von china oder den
usa vom himmel holen egal ob es bereits
kaputt ist oder eine gefahr darstellt
auf zweiter ebene ist es auch ein
militärisches problemen sobald wir
spezielle satelliten entwickeln die
dafür ausgelegt sind alte satelliten aus
dem orbit zu schubsen können sie das
gleiche natürlich auch mit
funktionierenden tun
schon jetzt ist der weltraum ein
politisches spielfeld satelliten sind
maßgeblich für die kommunikation von
militär und politik verantwortlich
wer auch immer den ersten angriff
satelliten entwickelt kann landesweiter
netzwerke oder das komplette gps
netzwerk vom himmel nehmen bitte erzähl
das übrigens nicht der neuen space force
aber zumindest hier in europa scheint
man da bereits politischen konsens
erreicht zu haben
2009 10 hat die europäische
raumfahrtagentur esa das kia space one
programm mit einem schweizer startup
angekündigt es soll die erste mission
werden bei der ein stück weltraumschrott
aus dem alten wieder entfernt wird mit
einem west bar satelliten wollen sie
dann so bald wie möglich anfangen
weltraumschrott aufzuräumen
dafür muss dieser vespa satellit aber
auch erst noch designt und gebaut werden
wie das genau umgesetzt werden soll ist
bisher noch nicht klar andere ideen den
weltraum aufzuräumen sind zum beispiel
ein riesiges auffangnetz das den müll
einfängt oder ein laser der den müll
ganz einfach weglässt
bisher sind viele dieser ideen aber noch
in den kinderschuhen wenn europa hier
mit gutem beispiel voran geht können wir
ja vielleicht darauf hoffen dass andere
länder mit einem größeren
raumfahrtprogramm auf den zug
aufspringen
darum soll es übrigens auch in einem
meiner nächsten videos gehen raumfahrt
in ländern die nicht die usa oder
russland sind denn auch andere länder
von denen jetzt vielleicht gar nicht
gedacht hätte haben ein riesiges arsenal
an raketen und satelliten
wenn ihr das video nicht verpassen
wollte dann abonniert gerne den kanal
und wenn jetzt auf kathrin unterstützt
dann könnt ihr dieses video vor allen
anderen sehen
aufräumen ist eine undankbare und
unprofitable aufgabe mit weltraumschrott
lässt sich bisher noch kein geld
verdienen außer vielleicht in dem man
die gegenstände als sammlerstücke
verkauft das bedeutet den weltraum
aufzuräumen bleibt wohl erst einmal
überzeugungsarbeit um eine katastrophe
vorzubeugen und wie schnell die räder
hier malen das kann man sich ja bei der
globalen klimakrise anschauen
dazu haben wir übrigens ein video
gemacht wie würden wissenschaftler den
klimawandel aufhalten wenn sie
deutschland regieren würden ein
gedankenexperiment dass ihr euch hier
anschauen könnt
ansonsten freue ich mich immer mit euch
in den kommentaren zu diskutieren ist es
ständiger fortschritt wert dass wir
dabei so viel müll produzieren und habe
hier ideen wie man diesen ganzen schrott
aus der umlaufbahn bekommt schreibt es
mir gerne unten in die kommentare
ansonsten bis dahin bleibt neugierig
patrick
[Musik]